hey what's up guys my name is achernar
and welcome to episode 2 of game
programming okay so yesterday we took a
look at creating a basic window like in
terms of resolution right we just set
three variables which essentially
control the size of our game for now
anyway because obviously we can change
them in the future
now today we're going to talk about
threads now threads are very very
important all right so the first thing I
want to do is just write one line of
code right
so private thread thread now essentially
what we're doing here is we're creating
a private object so that is only visible
to this class game dot java
and we're creating a thread right and
we've named a thread so what a thread is
a thread in Java and in general in
computing is it's basically almost like
a process within a process so if you
actually open up all your processes on
your computer right and you can do that
by oh just go on a task manager tom if
you're running a Java process for
example let me just find like this one
writes is like the Java room platform
during one of these within this process
is a bunch of other processes right so
it's not like we're creating a new
process no we're just creating like a
new sub process that's what you can that
that's what you can think of a threat as
being a sub process now the reason we're
doing this is because we want to be able
to do multiple things simultaneously
we've already got one thread right one
thread which actually just runs our a
program now we want to make another
thread to actually handle the game
itself so that's what that's what we're
doing here we're creating a new thread
object now we haven't started thread or
anything so at the moment it's just dead
but we've created an object out of it so
that now we can manipulate it into what
we want all right and we can do that by
um by making a method right so we're
gonna make a method now and it's gonna
be public now it's gonna be synchronized
and I'll explain what that means in a
second public synchronized void and
we'll just call a start right and inside
here all we're gonna do is type thread
equals new thread
before I go any further
I want to explain a few things first of
all synchronized a lot of you guys
probably gonna be wondering what
synchronized means now essentially I
don't want to really get into like too
deep into synchronized but essentially
we're just writing synchronized here
because we want like a I guess a
strategy for just preventing thread
interferences and memory consistency
errors alright and synchronize is a
great way to do this the reason is this
thread this this this thread thing is
gonna be visible to multiple threads
right because we've got multiple threads
running now we've got our first thread
which actually runs our program and as
well as you know exits out of our
program and then we've got our game
thread I could have named this game
thread in fact I probably will in a
second but um synchronized is just it
just ensures that there's no like inter
leaves or I guess overlaps of
instructions for this thread object
because since we're dealing with threads
here it's very important that we don't
screw up because if we do then well
that's bad the whole thing crashes in
fact our computer Cleavon lockdown
so it's very important that we do this
now what I want to do first of all
actually is make sure that our game
class actually implements runnable now
we'll get an error here and that's
alright but what this allows us to do is
actually make sure that this thread
object that we create we can actually
just put this in it now if we didn't
have runnable that we wouldn't be able
to do this now what this means is that
the new thread that they were creating
right will contain this game class right
hence hence this you know same thing as
writing new game but we actually want
this instance of game to be here and
that just means that this thread is
basically attached to this game object
now optionally we can give this thread a
name and as I mentioned it might be
useful so we just we'll just call it
display or we could have called a game
okay that's that's another parameter
when you're creating them a new thread
so um so yeah so now that we've created
our thread we need to start it because
essentially what we've done is we've
created a method to start thread so
let's start the thread we do that simply
by writing a thread don't start now what
happens is one when we actually run the
start method when we call the start
method we'll create a new thread object
and we'll start that thread object so
essentially we've created a new thread
by this now similarly to starting this
we also want a method to stop our thread
and and the reason is usually in applets
you want to be able to stop the applet
because if we're doing this in a web
browser think of it think of it this way
if we're running a if we're if we're
just running a game on the desktop and
we want to close it we close it and then
that's the end of it but we might want
to stop like Java needs a way to stop a
thread in an applet because you might
still want to continue using your web
browser even after you actually stop now
the problem without stopping is that
even if you stop for example even if you
like I don't know close a tab containing
an applet what you might notice is the
music actually keeps playing and that's
because the thread wasn't properly
stopped we haven't actually shut down
the game properly so we want to be able
to shut down our game safely and
properly if we're using this in an
applet now the way we do that is
creating a stop method so what we need
to do is go public again I'm gonna make
it synchronized because we're dealing
with threads here and we don't want any
memory consistency errors or anything
like that
we'll call it stop and essentially all
we're gonna do is I guess wait for the
threat to die right we've closed it
let's just join all the threads together
so we call thread dot join right and
you'll notice that it actually throws an
exception so what we need to do is
actually try and catch that exception so
if we put try over here and catch and
interrupted oops
make sure spell it right interrupted
exception a and I don't know we'll just
print the staff tries because that's
what everyone does basically what we're
gonna do is we're gonna try and do this
now if this fails then we're just gonna
I guess exit out of our program because
well we don't really care because we
failed catching the thread that doesn't
matter
let's just leave it at that all right
and that is honestly a simple
as it is to UM to
stop thread all right so what will
happen is when we actually get into um
into applets we'll be able to call this
method to stop the applet so um yeah
anyway that's pretty much our intro our
introduction to threads tomorrow we're
gonna take a look at um probably an
actual game loop pretty much as well as
the run method to actually make our game
I guess you know have a bit of um you
know essentially to run is what I'm
trying to say one more thing you can't
follow me on Twitter if you would like
the link is in the description a lot of
you guys have a lot of questions and
asked me I'm you know when the next
video is coming out the best way
honestly to get my attention is Twitter
and as well as receive updates from me
in terms of you know where the episode
is that so yeah also if you like this
video please hit the like button and
I'll see you guys tomorrow with um with
a new video so yeah bye guys bye
[Music]
you
[Music]